- Ladies and gentlemen give it up
for the host of today's show
Jay Leno
(upbeat music)
(cheering)
- Thank you very much.
Thank you, that's very kind.
Thank you very much.
Oh thank you, thank you,
thank you.
(cheering)
I can see your disappointment.
You cover it well, but
thank you, thank you.
Well, let me explain Kelly's
taking a personal day.
You know, she's a mom and
we get into the holidays.
When you have kids, you guys
all know how that works.
So she asked grandpa Jay to come in
and kind of fill in a little bit.
Now, some of you might know
Kelly and I have a history,
not that kind of history.
(laughing)
Mine was the first talk show she ever did,
when she got this show,
she called me and said,
what advice do you have?
So I kind of passed on some of the advice
that Johnny Carson gave me.
And it served us both very well.